we are going to continue scaling up our
coverage of the 2018 midterm elections
as we get closer and closer now seven
and a half weeks away and what I want to
talk to you about today is that there is
a major major growing problem for
Republicans and for Donald Trump and as
a result of Donald Trump's lack of
popularity in the Midwest
okay the overall advantage for Democrats
in the upcoming midterms has grown
significantly over the last two months
and there are all sorts of different
voter models you can look at that look
at the Senate that look at the House of
Representatives based on leaning and
likely seats and different likely voter
models but the big picture is that the
numbers have gone significantly in the
direction of Democrats over the last two
months the voting group that is
responsible for that swing away from
Republicans and Trump endorsed
Republicans and towards Democrats are
voters in the Midwest of the United
States of America they have swung 13
percentage points since July towards
Democrats and it's not just one poll
there's this national NPR Marist Poll
which shows that the 2018 midterm sort
of outlook has swung significantly
toward Democrats over the last two
months if you look at Marist
state-by-state polls you will see that
the big changes are in the Midwest and
it is again away from Republicans and
towards Democrats now this could
actually be this it's almost like kind
of obvious but it doesn't happen that
often this could actually be people in
the Midwest realizing that Trump is
screwing them big time and is screwing
them specifically more than he's
screwing most other people in the United
States of America Trump's abortive
tariffs which I've been talking about
for months are bad for mostly everyone
but they're especially bad for people in
the Midwest who work in farming and who
work in manufacturing to pick a couple
of industries wouldn't it be wonderful
if quite simply people reacted to
politicians
passing policy that's bad for them by
saying I'm going to vote for someone
else the rich do it right the rich see
very clearly okay
this is who's going to give me a tax cut
or this is who's going to give my
business a tax reduction and that's who
I'm going to vote for and I'm gonna use
the money that I have surplus money
because I've been getting those tax cuts
from Republican presidents for a long
time and I am going to refund all it
back in to people who are going to pass
laws that are good for my checkbook but
good good for my pocketbook good for my
bank account whatever whatever metaphor
or analogy you want to use what if the
farming industry and the manufacturing
industry in the Midwest simply said this
guy screwing us we're going to vote for
someone else we're going to put aside
what might be differences on social
issues and we're gonna vote for somebody
who is not actively part of the problem
that is screwing us day after day after
day now let's talk about what needs to
happen in the Midwest and in other parts
of the country in November polls are
nice but voting is what counts and
President Obama former President Obama
has been talking about this and so have
many others whatever the polls say these
Midwesterners and everybody else must
get out and vote and we are going to
start putting together possible sort of
result scenarios 5:38 has been doing
some really good work on this and there
are other websites that are doing really
really good mathematical work here and
all of that matters but every single
person that watches the show that
listens to the show needs to treat
whatever race you can participate in by
voting or by phone banking or by
volunteering or donating treat every
race as 50/50 make sure you were
registered to vote and actually do vote
but then if you have the means to donate
donate if you have the time to volunteer
or if you can make time and I think that
you should do that and when you look at
these different election previews like
the one on five thirty eight.com check
out some of those races they'll often be
ranked as safe Democrat and Republican
likely Democrat and Republican
leaning Democrat and Republican those
leaning and likely are the ones where
get out the vote and phone banking and
all of that type of activism can
actually make a difference so please
please do it this is a massive you
should be engaged period because this
stuff matters and if you watch the show
you probably already are engaged to some
degree otherwise you'd be watching or
listening to something else but this is
an opportunity in terms of the
importance of these midterms that does
not come up all the time it has been a
long time since there have been midterms
of this degree of consequence if you
don't plan to vote okay
I'm speaking directly to you now please
email me and explain to me why you don't
plan to vote in November I can't think
of any good reasons not to vote in
November and if you don't plan to vote
other than you know there's some
logistical reason why you're not going
to be voting if you're gonna choose not
to vote please tell me I want to hear
from you and I also want to hear from
you on Twitter where you can find me at
des Pakman follow me there you can also
follow the show on twitter at david
pakman show we'll take a quick break we
have a fantastic program for you today
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka is a
great service that I use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink as'
I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS Jobs and there is a great new book BS
Jobs by David Graeber which I listened
to on blinka they're constantly adding
new books to the platform you will never
run out of fascinating and critically
acclaimed books to enjoy and our
audience can get a seven day free trial
by going to blink Escom slash Pakman if
you're watching on YouTube
I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about five bucks a month that's be Li NK
is t.com /pa k ma n